and as you can see for yourself
helicopter shots there of the cortege
making its way
slowly through the
gloomy streets of west london
the crowds
scattered along that road it is uh as
you can see for yourself a dual
carriageway at the moment and so the
crowd's fairly sparse it's not like that
when we get into the
the pavements
and the streets
of the center of london itself it's
certainly not like that around
buckingham palace
where i am now where we can see
hundreds thousands of people waiting
waiting patiently for their
their moment
to glimpse to see that
coughing
bearing her majesty the queen queen
elizabeth ii to see for themselves
to be part of a moment a true moment
that will be remembered for
generations centuries to come in british
history for them to say that in part
that i was there but in the maine to say
that i was there
to pay my own respects to have my own
private thoughts about
what she what the royal family meant to
me many of them we've talked haven't we
of the
last few days and will over the
weeks to come about to the thousands
hundreds of thousands of people she met
during the course of her reign the
impression
she made each and
every one of those people having their
own particular story to tell and now so
many of them
wanting
to be here to see
something that's
been ever presents
almost in their lives
the statistic the bear statistic that
more than 80 percent of the population
of the
uk have never known any other monarch of
course there hasn't haven't other than
queen elizabeth ii
well the pneumonic king charles
has had a busy day himself it continues
he spent the day
in northern ireland
meeting
representative there of of all
communities and then attending a service
of tribute and reflection for his mother
at saint anne's cathedral in belfast he
flew back then about
an hour before back from belfast about
an hour before to the same uh to the
same base to our af northlake
and made his way we saw him arrive in
buckingham palace
about an hour ago the queen consult with
him as well
and they wait to receive
the coffin where it will rest overnight
for the family members and of course
members
of buckingham palace staff to pay their
own tributes
and our royal correspondent rhiannon
mills is here with me as we watch those
scenes and
somehow the weather
yeah i don't know it seems appropriate
doesn't it ryan and the the gloom
the damp
the drizzle the
undimmed appetite
desire of people to gather to congregate
to witness for themselves to pay as i
say their own respects
i think it feels so reflective doesn't
it of the
that sense of shock that many people are
feeling
um it is only seven days ago that in
balmoral the queen was carrying out that
last important constitutional duty only
seven days ago um appointing her
15th prime minister
who we then saw liz trust as part of the
welcome party there at raf northhold
well i you know it was exactly a week
ago when i was standing in the damn
downing street it must be said well all
eyes were on raf norfolk for the return
of the new prime minister and to think
it
it has all it feels like it's all
happened so quickly
the one thing that really struck me as
we saw
her coming back in that that enormous
gray aircraft
was just how tiny her coffin looked in
it and
yes she was
she was tiny really in physical stature
but she was the most enormous
international figure
and what we're seeing now and what we've
already seen to a degree in edinburgh
is the fact that she had just this
incredible impact beyond measure
yes on
dignitaries on politicians that she had
those important official meetings with
but also with the people now that we are
seeing lining the streets so many of
them have their own
memories of her whether they'd simply
seen her on television but they'd
gathered outside of buckingham palace
before for those big milestone moments
or would they actually met her in person
and they talk about her kindness
and her connection
and so
if you look at the hearse there you can
see there are there are lights inside
the hearse and that is deliberate i've
just had some information through which
she said the state the state hearse to
be used um it was designed by the raw
household and jaguar land rover you
might remember that we saw that hearse
was designed by jaguar land rover
for the duke of edinburgh and that was
certainly unique in itself and the queen
was consulted on the plans for this
hearse
it's finished in raw claret the same
colour as official rule and state
vehicles that are kept in the raw me's
at buckingham palace and used by members
of the royal family on official duties
the vehicle also features her majesty
the queen's personal royal cipher and
they say the state hearse was designed
to make sure that members of the public
have a clear view of her coffin as it
travels on this journey but also
after her funeral as it travels from
london to windsor
we can see that illustrated right now in
that
darkening evening with the lights inside
illuminating the coffin so people can
see for themselves
and you have to remember that
accompanying her
on
all the final journeys we've seen so far
the movement from balmoral to edinburgh
then edinburgh back to rf northhold and
now
this final
journey here to buckingham palace
she has at all times been accompanied by
her daughter princess anne
and as the plane flew into raf northhold
we were given a statement from the
princess royal in which she said i was
fortunate to share the last 24 hours of
my dearest mother's life it has been an
honor and a privilege to accompany her
on her final journeys witnessing the
love and respect shown by so many on
these journeys has been both humbling
and uplifting we will all share unique
memories i offer my thanks to each and
every one who share their own sense of
loss
we may have been reminded how much of
her presence and contribution to our
national identity we took for granted i
am also so grateful for the support and
understanding offered to my dear brother
charles as he accepts the added
responsibilities of the monarch to my
mother
the queen
thank you
i want to bring in patrick harrison
on that but first of all patrick
obviously just explained you used to be
press secretary for
charles
prince charles as he then was just
we're saying it's it's sinking in now as
you as you witness that scene yeah of a
woman you you knew so well yes indeed
and it's incredibly poignant isn't it i
mean we've already had
many poignant moments but uh here is
another one and uh people waiting
patiently in the gloom
showing the kind of stoicism and
constancy which they associate with her
majesty
now
desperate and keen to pay their final
respects
to this woman who has been the constant
in their lives for so many years and
fascinating to get that detail that
you've just explained about the hearse
is so important in the planning of all
this
that members of the public who uh wait
for hours for a glimpse get get a real
opportunity to see see the coffin as it
goes past very practical very practical
yeah making sure that
well in life in death as many people as
possible
were able to see her she always said she
had to be seen to be believed and now as
the coffin slowly makes its way here
towards buckingham palace
that's exactly what's happening with
those lights inside the hearse and
patrick on that statement that rhiannon
just read out a personal statement
by the princess royal just that last bit
of it we're seeing it very clearly
aren't we this
the senior royals the two
eldest children
of her majesty
really
i don't know taking control the princess
royal
traveling with that coffin from balmoral
to edinburgh from edinburgh to london
and the king doing his duties traveling
around the realm now waiting at
buckingham palace
to receive the coffin well absolutely
and both the king and the princess royal
have always enjoyed a very close
relationship and and of course we both
were very close to their mother so it
seems a very appropriate way in which
they're performing those uh
dual roles i thought it was particularly
notable that the princess royal was part
of the vigil last night that's the first
time that a woman has been published
the vigil of the princess vigil of the
princes absolutely so there we've seen a
change there which i think is a very
significant one and a very welcome one
that the princess royal was part of that
vigil and of course she has uh
accompanied her mother from balmoral all
the way down to edinburgh and now today
from edinburgh all the way down to to
london and as we're seeing now um in
through the center of london
back
to the palace that everybody associates
with the royal family buckingham palace
the site of so many royal events over
the years and i'm sure they're all
coming into our mind now as we
watch these pictures as the queen makes
her final journey back to buckingham
palace yeah that's uh we understand uh
somewhere around
shepherd's bus for those that know
london and the crowds
much deeper there
some cheering
obviously the flash of the cameras and
on the other side of the road you can
see the traffic jams well um
i'm sure they're not
too upset to be stopping themselves in
that traffic floor to get a glimpse out
the window
at the hearse carrying the coffin off
the majesty the queen to buckingham
palace let's talk again to our oil
commentator
alastair bruce
and alistair it's uh
it's a very modern industrial scene in
in a sense this center of one of the
world's greatest cities but
it echoes in antiquity as well the the
bearing of a monarch
ultimately to her final place of rest
london was bombed and bleeding during
the blitz she
lived through that and watched her
father the king deal with
the challenges of wartime
she then joined the army
joined the
army territorial service the auxiliary
territorial service and
then through her reign london has grown
exponentially it has changed it has
evolved
it is a totally different city
from the one
that she found herself returning to in
1952
and in which she was crowned a year
later
but it's a city that she
loved to work from
she turned where she lived at buckingham
palace into a real home
and she was able from there to
meet all members of her household
private sectors regular meetings with
the prime minister every week that
parliament was in session
and
she really is coming home
and all the way in through what is a
busy city
returning
at the end of a day's work
they are weaving her through this scene
while people will want to
salute their sovereign passing by
albeit
fleetingly
but lit as she is with the royal
standard
it catches on a dreary evening
the reds the golds the blues
that tell a story about the nation that
she ruled
as sovereign
and it
also has marked wherever she's been
throughout her reign
occasionally she flew her own standards
when she went to the commonwealth
countries but
pretty much everywhere she was
the royal standard flew and
london cabbies knew when she was home
it was something to look out for for
people coming to buckingham palace as
part of their tourist visit
and
that is now the case for her son the
king
who will be waiting for the return
his mother he'll be joined obviously by
princess anne who's coming with
the queen here but
all four of the queen's children will be
waiting their spouses and all of the
queen's grandchildren
all eight of them with their spouses too
so
a real homecoming for the queen
to her capital city
to her palace
and to her home
and alistair
to her place of birth her city of birth
though
she wasn't born at buckingham palace
no 17 brewton street just up the road
doesn't really exist
no in quite the same way that it did and
in fact i think
there's a hotel where she was born
now and certainly her parents then moved
to
our house
on
piccadilly and the intention was that
she'd be yes a royal princess
but the daughter of one of the king's
younger brothers
but then that king
abdicated left the united kingdom went
to live in france
and
her father became king
absolutely
in his view ill-prepared for it
and at least the queen had a few years
to
study from her father all the
constitutional elements of what she
needed to do
and so when he died very young she was
well prepared on the one
sense but
she had
in her principal advisor
prime minister sir winston churchill she
united him actually gave him the order
of the garter quite soon after
she acceded to the throne
and
he was responsible
preparing her for the first stages of
that reign
and i think it was quite significant
that waiting for her at northholt was
the 15th prime minister of her reign who
she had only invited
to former government a week ago today
quite extraordinary the
pace of events when you describe them
like that
and alistair as we we look at the the
hearse and we
we've heard what you've told us what
rhiannon's told us about the the special
design to
allow people
to get their view
of the cortege of the coffin itself of
course the
that coffin
has been a long time in the design
english oak 30 years in the design and
lead-lined
there is a wonderful cheer happening
here
in the pouring rain for the queen
yes it's
weighted
it's
sad that now its duty has
come to but
the care we are going to see in all the
detail surrounding the preparation of
this final salute from the united
kingdom to their sovereign of over 70
years will be very moving i think
when
she arrives at buckingham palace a very
a very intimate moment will take place
not only will she be met by her family
but she was appointed
in 1942
by her father in the middle of the war
to be colonel of the grenadier guards
and when she became sovereign
obviously she became colonel in chief of
that regiment
but she also became the company
commander
of her own company known as queen's
company first battalion grenadier guards
and when she arrives at buckingham
palace
her own company will step forward
and they will form
the bearer party
to carry her into her palace
her relationship with the grenadier
guards is the longest
that she has
with any military organization
and so the intimacy of that relationship
is entirely profound
well patrick and uh
charles's former press secretary is here
with me as
we work out
where that core taj is which not too
very far away now from buckingham palace
15 20 minutes perhaps and just so struck
by
obviously the size of the crowds that
have gathered here been added to by the
moment people being able to follow
the progress of the state hearse on
their phones updating themselves on the
information but also
just the patience
it's very noticeable business the
stillness there's been a a change of
atmosphere over the last 20 minutes or
so as a as a stillness has uh descended
if you like by buckingham palace we've
been watching it here um and as it
becomes
darker and darker and people
watching on their phones
uh
is coming closer and closer uh towards
them of course this is a a feature of
the event as it's happening now
that people can follow it of course on
their phones
in the crowd so everybody uh waiting
outside patiently under their umbrellas
uh i know exactly where uh where that
where we are in the process as we come
uh towards buckingham palace
and interesting you know there was some
whooping and and cheering i mean it's
not the funeral um and that's
people showing their appreciation yeah
absolutely in edinburgh as well we heard
cheers
as well as a hushed silence
but i think when you see the the speed
of
the hearse
relatively slowly driving past
it does slow down the pace of what we've
seen unfold in a
relatively short space of time it was
only on thursday evening that her death
was announced and in some ways there has
at times felt like this frenetic pace as
we've we've tried to come to terms with
her death but also
the process and the ceremonial that has
to happen
because we automatically have a new king
and of course
king charles has has guided us through
that in many ways and i think what's
been very striking to me is is how the
royal family have wanted us all to feel
involved it was made clear at a briefing
that was held by at the palace that yes
for him of course
the state duties
kick in immediately
that is of course important to him he
knows he has to continue the
constitutional role that he's been
handed by his mother
but his primary role he believes at the
moment is to lead
the nation lead his family leave the
world in this moment of mourning and
making sure that we all feel part of
that already scotland had their moment
they were able to pay this very fulsome
tribute because of the nature of the
fact that she died in scotland and now
she's making her way into central london
where so many people have gathered over
the years to join with her
in those huge celebrations for those
milestone moments
and isn't it breathtaking in many ways
to think that it was only in june the
start of june that many of us were here
as the crowds again gathered
and cheered for her
as she walked out onto the balcony at
buckingham palace
surrounded by her family and that is why
this final return is going to feel so
poignant to so many
let's just uh update people who may just
be joining us some that
her majesty queen elizabeth ii is making
her final journey home well home to
buckingham palace is that the the state
hearse
simple cortege five or six cars one of
them containing a daughter the princess
royal in her husband following behind
those three police outriders at the
front
a company rehearsed through the
dark dank streets of west london
it's transported
that hers and the coffin down the a40 on
its way to buckingham palace it landed
at um
raf norfolk in west london
well about
45 perhaps 50 minutes ago just before
seven o'clock this evening um
the heavens opened
the drizzle started a grey sky descended
and now night has fallen and as we've
been seeing
through all the traffic there the stop
traffic people managing
depending on
the nature of the streets that the host
is passing through to
to grab a moment or two to pay their own
farewells and respects
to that hearse so we are now
15 or 20 minutes away from the
hearse and the coffin arriving at
buckingham palace to be received
by the king and then it will rest in the
bow room in buckingham palace
overnight before being
moved in procession
through the center of london all those
ceremonial sites where so many drooping
the colors took place so many
jubilees in actual fact
into westminster hall
where thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people will be
able to
pay their respects
until
monday morning
the day of the state funeral itself and
patrick harrison you mentioned that
vigil of the princes we will see that
again we expect but we don't know
precisely when in westminster hall yes i
don't think we have the details of that
yet so what that we'll have to wait and
see but obviously that lying in state in
westminster hall is an incredibly
important opportunity for the people who
will cue no doubt for hours uh to to pay
their respects uh to to the late queen
it is quite a sight it was quite a sight
last night wasn't just those those
moments you mentioned the princess royal
there
just those royals in
their reflection and
members of the public walking past
absolutely and also when you think about
that incredibly busy schedule that the
king has and other members of the royal
family have to have that moment where
they are standing
quietly in reflection for their mother
by by the coffin what was was i thought
an incredibly poignant moment uh for the
king who otherwise has such a very busy
schedule and just to reflect on another
poignant moment as
the hearse the coffin passes along the
west way in
central london the elevated section of
the a40 and of course passes
grenfell tower
swathed
empty
a memorial
to those that died in that awful
conflagration
four or five years ago
and one remembers rhiannon and then the
the thoughts of her majesty the queen
that she expressed so volubly about that
tragedy she did and and she visited with
um prince william and i remember those
pictures coming in and you had people
literally wailing at times
in the background as
as prince william accompanied his
grandmother
but it was one of those moments where
she realized that she needed to provide
this this figure of stability and
reassurance
and also
reminding us that certainly over the
last few years
her family have very much stepped in
to help support her
it was it was an incredibly moving day
around also that that same time i
remember her going up to manchester
around the time of the manchester arena
bombing and standing by the bedside of
a young girl who'd been injured and just
saying it was wicked it was wicked what
happened
that of course is the dual role of
monarchy isn't it it's to be there
celebrate the the moments but also to be
there in those moments of tragedy as
well yeah and and i think sometimes
people reflected on the fact that the
queen was so private and sometimes
unemotional we didn't often see her shed
a tear in public
but it didn't mean that she was uncaring
she connected with people and showed
that sense of reassurance and care in
in a whole multitude of ways and and who
can forget the speech that she she made
that national address during the
coronavirus pandemic where she said we
will meet again
and the reassurance that that brought to
so many at what was an incredibly
difficult time
one or two flowers
single stems being thrown
from the crowd there
as the cortege descends to westbourne
terrace from the
less accessible
elevated section of the
a40 to say now people can
really get closer
to the hearse to the coffin
to get those photographs
and
as we've been saying patrick
it's designed for that purpose the state
hearse
they want to show that coffin they want
people to see absolutely share the
moment absolutely as rhianne mentioned
earlier this is the king leading the
nation in mourning and uh in all the
plans that uh underpin what we're seeing
now it is about ensuring that the public
can share in that uh in this moment and
able to uh in in their way share in the
moment express their
sorrow and also
their thankfulness
for uh for the queen
let's talk to alistair again our royal
commentator and
alastair
it's the simplicity
of this cortege a hearse
a few cars
outright is yes
but
the contrast with what we we will see
when the
the full force the might of the british
state and its armed forces pay tribute
to a monarch in a state funeral
it's going to be very very very
different but something about the
simplicity
of this
it's not even a formal ceremony
no and it's for every family that has
lost someone that they love very dearly
following a hearse is very often a part
of the funerary process
and it carries its sense of
finality
and
people react to it in different ways
death is so
so challenging to every emotion and
sense and the way people mourn is always
different
but this is somebody who everybody knew
and
therefore everybody as princess anne
said in her statement is dealing with it
in their own with their own memories
but the cohesive reality of seeing
the late sovereign who was so
sparkly eyed with that almost impish
young grin
when she was waiting to meet her
15th prime minister
it's difficult to realize
that that smile has gone
and yet
you're right tomorrow after this
rain-covered return
she will be
swept into a royal procession
of all the armed forces
making their way from
the palace where she lived
to the grandeur
of that massive westminster hall
where
coronation processions have been formed
back into the medal medieval times
where
parliament used to meet in the ancient
times and built by
william ii
and in a sense it will be the gathering
point for her ancestors to call her
back from life
to join the animals of history and the
way in which it will be done
will be so elegantly perfect
so nobody
and carefully measured
that i think without doubt
it will be something
that all of us can join with
and feel a part of
and we still watch those scenes as the
cortege makes its way through the center
of london getting ever closer now to
buckingham palace just
to the north side of hyde park and
notable there that
some of the drivers
getting out of their cars people on
bicycles dismounting clapping
taking photographs earlier one or two
single flowers
being thrown towards the hearse some
traffic jams
well
a regular feature
of commuting of driving in central
london i don't think anyone
caught up in them
today
regrets
that
at all because they've been able causing
them themselves they've been
able to see
the hearse carrying the queen's coffin
towards buckingham palace and towards
a personal greeting a personal farewell
from members of her own family led by of
course the new king king charles the
queen consort
her other children
and their children
her grandchildren will greets will
receive
that coffin here at buckingham palace
before it's born
for one last night in buckingham palace
into the bow room there where they will
be able to have their own private
thoughts where members of staff at
buckingham palace will be able to
have a thought or two
before it is moved
and as alistair was telling us before
really the state takes over
then
we realize
the moniker's gone the queen is dead
long live the king the
the movement of that coffin tomorrow at
222
precisely
that planning
will take the coffin the very short
distance to westminster hall
the crowds are already there we've been
reporting on them some people
let's just listen to some of the sounds
there's some of the people no doubt
on those pavements
witnessing the rehearse for themselves
will
now go to the banks of the thames all
the way back to the tower of london
start queueing to be
some of the people who will be
able to witness for themselves that
official the the lying in state
we're now approaching
marble arch
the end of oxford street
london's
main shopping street
a right turn then down park lane
we'll bring it down to
high park corner and then
the last short stretch down constitution
hill
into buckingham palace
patrick harrison and uh a route that was
just
now we're so close to the palace just
just second nature to her majesty she
has made this route
many many many times uh and obviously
very familiar uh part of london to her
majesty and all those members of the
royal family who are waiting to receive
her in buckingham palace and uh it's
very striking isn't it this very public
procession of the hearse
into buckingham palace and then back
into that personal
family moment
overnight
with members of the royal family and
also members of the royal household and
you don't need me to tell you that that
loyalty is hugely prized within the
household and the household will very
much
wish to pay their own respects
across this evening as well and before
as you say
she then makes that journey over to
to westminster hall where the state then
takes over so you've got a public
journey into a private family and
household moment overnight and then
across and into that state moment later
on which of course tomorrow then uh
begins uh the uh lying in state where
members of the public can then pay their
respects
alastair bruce we're only
half a mile or so away now as we look at
the aerial shot of park lane approaching
hyde park corner
and not too long before we see the
arrival of the hearse
at the gates of buckingham palace before
it goes through the grand entrance
and will be received by members of her
family
dermot you were mentioning how londoners
seeing this glimpse of the queen going
past londoners are
so used over the last 20 30 40 years to
just wandering along the pavements and
suddenly seeing the queen's car come
past as she went off to the city of
london or
to open something here or there all
round london
and
they've come out tonight
and they're seeing the sovereign past
through these roads for
the final time
and
londoners have
responded very warmly to the queen
throughout her reign because she's been
such a constant
after watching her son the king
recall and reflect upon the loss of
queen elizabeth ii
and make so much of
the constitution
it is
fitting that her last
part of this journey will be up
constitution hill
she passed there also absolutely house
and every year she used to receive a
trickler from the duke of wellington who
was her friend
to recall the battle of waterloo in the
schedule of
events
[Music]
that she did every year
[Applause]
along constitution hill she will come to
the queen victoria memorial
and to buckingham palace
she'll pass by
the memorial to the royal air force
bombers from the second world war
which she unveiled not all that long ago
and this is where the nation has had its
eyes since we got the news
that the queen had died people have been
gathering at this palace the
icon of her reign and of the monarchy
itself
in the journey of
our late sovereign
this is her final coming home
uh
passing by the side of the palace where
she lived
where she took the dogs for the walks
where she could be alone during the week
of her duties
[Applause]
going around the queen victoria memorial
to give more people gathered here
a chance to see the queen
[Applause]
at the end of her coronation in 1953 the
great gold state coach
brought the young queen through this
centre gate to start her reign
her duty done
she returns to the same palace
with such a vast book of
duties done
engagements completed
[Applause]
her service
finally completed for the united kingdom
[Music]
within the quadrangle of buckingham
palace awaits the first battalion coal
stream guards
three officers 101
guardsmen ready to
give a royal
salute to the colonel in chief
you